[Music]
at the end and hopefully um by the end
of the session we've answered most of
your questions
so thank you very much for coming my
name's sarah i'm the governance manager
here
and that has responsibilities of
actually looking after all 35 elected
members that we have
ensuring that you have the right
information to be able to do your role
as an elected member and providing new
guidance along that journey over the
next three years
i'm also the deputy electoral officer
and will be your primary first author
contact over electoral matters over the
coming few months
and i'll probably receive some of your
nomination forms over the next couple of
weeks
i'll also introduce jeffrey milward our
recently appointed chief executive
following the retirement of jim harlan
jeff has been at the council here for a
number of years
including being our finance and business
manager for the last 15 plus years
guiding us through very prudent
financial management
and then we have anthony who we contract
as our electoral officer
which not only oversees
all the election processes but also
handles the vote paper distribution and
that most important part of the vote
count
in a couple of months time
so i'm going to hand over to jeff for a
little bit of a quick intro
about
the district and the council
and then um
i have a couple words i mean anthony
will take you through a lot of the
electoral processes and as i say we'll
have q a at the end of the evening
we do have some paperwork over there
should you wish to taking your way
nomination forms and our electoral
handbook there'll be further information
on the website later this week so we
strongly suggest you keep an eye on our
website on the elections page over the
next few weeks because we will
continually update that with varying
bits of information that will
help you along the way
um welcome everyone it's great to see
you good tune out
um
this is the last time i did this i was
in the same sort of situation where i
was acting uh so my normal role was
seriously
i'm the
general manager of finance and business
support so if you want to ask me any
financial questions tonight i'll know
them
halfway up hard
so just i've got about seven slides here
before i hand it over to anthony
and just about just the general facts
about the council so you can see there
we've got a land area of 200 and a
quarter of
a million years of land going from the
waimakaru
waimakari river through to the outside
of the ashley
basically from the hills of oxford
through to the sea
population 66 000 people that's a little
bit underestimated now we're
pushing towards 69 000 people
i'm growing around about two and a half
three percent per annum so we've been a
growth district
uh for at least the last 35 years
which is pretty unusual when you look at
the councils around new zealand
uh houses 25
000 houses about 27 and a half thousand
raidable properties
six that might interest you is
over six and a half thousand businesses
i didn't think there was that many until
we added them all up
uh and lifestyle block holdings we're
one of the largest in new zealand we've
got around about six six and a half
thousand of those as well so
quite a quite a dispersed population um
district equity is 1.8 billion you might
have heard in the news about three
waters that it's around about six
hundred thousand six hundred million
uh our operational spends it fluctuates
uh
we're around 86
to 100 million depending on what types
of programs we've got
in store
and
capital expenditure over the next
that should be over 10 years
so we basically have to categorise them
into three areas for replacements which
got 163 million 129 million on
improvements
and 236 million
on growth projects which are generally
funded from development contributions
and debt depending on
you know what's what the growth is for
of course
purpose of local government so they're
straight out of the local government act
2002 which is basically
our rules and by which we move by and
it's to enable local democr sorry
democratic local decision making
in action by and on behalf of our
communities
and so that's quite important
we keep on reminding the local
government minister that he is the first
part of his name or title that he's
representing his local government
although he's in central government
uh and it's to promote the the welfares
the four wellbeings
so it's a social economic environmental
cultural world
and every all of everything that we do
here in terms of community outcomes is
pointed towards those poor wellbeings
uh it's a picture of some of the things
we get involved in
unlike some businesses which are just
centered just on one thing we've got
literally 30 or 40 different businesses
ranging from the three waters to solid
waste roading
one of the one of the surveys they did
about six or seven years ago which gave
a confidence rating for local
governments of 28 percent
very very low
worried the second quite a lot
a lot of them didn't know that we
actually did groaning
which is quite a basic
fundamental
our actual confidence rating sits up
into the 80s and 90s so once again we're
a little bit different to a lot of
councils
with the only double a rated
excellence council council in new
zealand
apart from wellington but we're the only
one that's got it twice under review
so
we pride ourselves for that
and then
basically um
what it's all about so we've got 129 i
think it's more more than that pieces of
legislation that governs
and that's
we formulate the district's
strategic direction and that's through
our long-term plan so every three years
we're required to do a long long term
plan
uh once again unlike businesses we we
are statutory required to do a 30-year
infrastructural strategy
this council does its whole life
strategy so we go out 150 years once
again we are
pretty well best practice in the country
for that at the moment
there's too many locals consuming
services and activities undertaken by
council so you'll see that um basically
connected to that is their revenue and
financing policy it identifies the
activities that we do the benefits it
costs and it allocates how we try and
charge those costs out
to the community via rates or fees and
charges
so that's that's an important document
that we use to actually set these
and the quantity of rates which is the
portion so you take a library or a
swimming pool library's predominantly
rates
uh swimming pool that's a 60 40 sport
based on its benefit and cost and
private usage
managing regulations upholding the law
and including the formulation and
divorce enforcement of bylaws so
basically that's pointing towards our
uh planning and regulatory uh
functioning of the council
through our building consents and
resource consents
so you see all these different
businesses coming in which you would
normally see just in one entity
we've got advocating on behalf of local
community with central government other
local authorities and agencies and two
things there is you'll see quite a lot
in the media three waters again
this council's advocating that um it
doesn't like the four entities approach
that they're better ways of doing
and providing for the three waters you
would have heard it
was sort of talking about two waters so
maybe
the message is getting through here
uh and the other one is um you know what
are we going to do with the stadium
in christchurch
really debatable so
the other sort of things that you will
hear in the media that we're going to
contribute
we haven't actually talked about that
with our communities yet and so that's
something we need to consult with before
we even
uh the council even uh talks about
committing to that so the other sorts of
issues that you'll be involved in
uh
relationship with knight to guriri
that's a very important relationship
with us
and and it's
getting quite a lot of prominence at the
moment and
you know
that's a an important
piece of work for us to make sure that
is kept
environment environmental management
through the district plan so
you'll see at the moment we've got a
proposed district plan there we've got
an operative one and a proposed one last
time we did this talk about seven or
eight years before we got to
an operative side of it after we put it
out
so
once again a very very important plan
which determines
you know where
our
populations grow
what they look like
and the types of housing and so forth
that's contained within those areas
and
there's probably a lot more than this
but these are the key ones but ensuring
local communities encouraged to be part
of the decision-making process of local
government
now you'll find
our council
is probably one of the few now that
actually actually go out every year and
cons and consult on its independent we
do that
they keep it relevant but also to make
sure that its communities is not just
you know tested every three years but we
test them every year and so we still got
it right we still got it right
so that's what we go out for annual plan
and
it's one thing as a staff member i
really appreciate our council journal
so
what has it been elected member all
about
well it's a big deal
that's a serious put that in big
inserted and it is a big deal
um
it's it's not
um just putting your name forward and
getting lifted it's it's more than that
it's it's not a five-minute job our
counselors
uh and board members
uh put in a tremendous amount of hours
probably just as much if not more than
the staff members do
because
they come to the council meetings
they're out in the public they're
listening and gathering all that
information
and and they're using that when they
come around and debate around the table
this is what i'm hearing and so forth
so it's not to be taken lightly
you are representing and you're leading
your community that you're actually
living in
um
and it's it's really important and
one thing that you just can't
underestimate
your advocacy uh and
representing the
uh and lead the districts you're the
eyes and ears that missed that one but i
was just explaining it before
uh and your advocacy and governance
that's what you're there for to advocate
and govern
and there's a skill set in the
candidate's guidebook and i think
there's another slide that covers some
of that
yeah so the core competencies that we're
looking for is you know genuine interest
for the issues faced by little
communities
relate to a wide range of people with
strong people skills
competent listening and public speaking
skills express ideas and clearly
express ideas clearly and be results
focused
understand analyse and resolve complex
issues
understand governance versus management
very important one um the way i see a
counsellor is probably a little bit
different to others but i see a
counsellor and a board member like a
true board that you you have in the
in a business they are there to govern
that business and look after it make
sure it's got the right policies
strategies and everything in place
but different to a board is that you are
there
advocating on behalf of the residents in
ratepayers
you are there
it's a little bit different to a board
and i think it has a lot more
responsibilities
and not to be taken long
and
counsellor i think district-wide on
issues
our councillors do currently and that's
what we try and promote
but knowing that the board members
themselves the elected on the boards
there's a lot of crossover issues
take a road or something that goes
through both boards
they need to be aligned and quite often
that happens and we have all board
meetings which try and bring those
ideas together
and we board that out as well and
sometimes you get
presentations from police and so forth
that give you that a bit more emphasis
around communities
and commit to elected members code of
conduct so just like staff
that have to abide by our code of
conduct
so do our elected members and we have a
code of conduct which they
they actually
sign up to and
governs their behaviors and so forth so
very important document so everyone is
aligned and has the same culture and
same direction on everything
i think that's uh
that's why we'll spiel
and
uh we'll take some questions at the end
unless anybody's got any questions
right
[Music]
member
and it's
really really hard to give you a
definitive answer
every elected member puts in a different
level of um effort and at different
times of the year there will be ebbs and
flows
on work that you're involved in
um
and we'll come through to that but a
fair fair portion
um of people actually just see the
actual meetings the formal council
meetings that we have
is the time commitment
and in actual fact that's
the tip of the iceberg
um we currently have our formal council
meeting
once a month first tuesday of the month
has been for a number of years
but the new term when we gather the new
elected members together we will consult
with those members as to
whether that pattern continues or there
is a different day
council meetings will range from about
four to six hours
on those ordinary meetings
then we also have our ebbs and slows for
budget meetings
annual plan or long-term meetings
that will involve hearings and
deliberations
and they can be two to three days
9 a.m to 6 p.m kind of
days
so there are ins and flows through the
year on those standing committees are
our core committees we have four of
those
they generally meet also once a month we
can have two three or four committees
running on the same day
one after the other we try to actually
make the timetabling of our meetings to
be as efficient as your time as possible
so you're not popping in and out
here
for a half day here and an hour there
dotted through the week we try to
condense our business meetings to one
particular day
and saying that we have several other
committees such as our district
licensing committee that will meet on
demand
with their workflows
we have our mahitahi joint committee
that will meet every couple of months
we have
at least 50 different working groups
project steering groups
special interest meeting groups
that might involve just two or three
elected members working with staff from
a particular project
could be linked with your particular
portfolio if you're a councillor at the
time
some of those working groups daring
groups may only be for a very short time
two or three months
for a sleep project
others will run for the entire
three-year term
and they all have
terms of reference wrapped around them
the mural role i haven't seen our
current meal with less than 40 hours a
week yet
um probably 60 hours you've got average
of that dad
this is where you need a really
understanding family you're out
all day half the night every night of
the week your weekends are sucked up
with meetings community events
talking to constituents
so
the workload again is how much effort
you put in
a counsellor
trying to average a time would be maybe
two days a week to five days a week
again depending on
different events that are happening
around
the district
we can be impacted by central government
demands such as three waters the amount
of additional discussions that we have
going on on those things will take up
maybe more of a work
time
we do have some counsellors that do work
full-time or part-time and can
fortunately juggle their council
responsibilities with their other
responsibilities
that's no different than anybody else
just juggling what is their priorities
on that community board member not as
demanding they meet once a month for a
meeting that might be two to three hours
usually in the evenings
they may have the occasional workshop
through
that month as well
particularly if they're working on
submissions for
such things as annual plan or one or two
key submissions for central government
and they can submit in their own right
um
and then you're also meeting your
constituent she might be going out on
site visits to
have a look at an issue somebody's got a
tree that's shading the property and
it's a council tree that they want taken
down and things
all these things dotted around will take
time you'll have people ring you in the
middle of your dinner
and want to chat about
the barking dog down the road or all
sorts of things
so the amount of
time really varies partly on the role
that you're undertaking and partly on
the eta and how much you're putting into
the community
and their contact in you
my team manage and
coordinate over 300 meetings a year
that doesn't mean to say that every
council or every man has to go to every
one of those meetings
but that generates an awful lot of
agendas and an awful lot of reading
um that is another chunk of your time
quite often your weekend has spent a few
hours reading and preparation for the
meeting the following week
um there may be things that you need to
talk to senior staff about to get some
further background so that you really
are well prepared to go into that
meeting
as i say flexibility on your working is
really really key
on that
and for all of that effort
there is some payment involved
now the
remuneration for elected members is set
by the independent remuneration
authority
the same authority that sets the
remuneration for
members of parliament
they set the
rate for the mayor
into the community board members
and then they tell the council that you
have a certain remuneration
pool
and you are to then share that however
you see fit among your councillors
we have the ten councillors
and we have
in the new term um we have
555 000 it's been allocated as that
remuneration pool to be divided among
the councillors
and there are a couple of different
levels
there is a baseline counsellor which
would be about 48 000 a year we don't
pay that we actually have all our
councillors has
additional duties of portfolios
and cheering of the committees
and because they have those additional
duties they get a higher pay
the deputy mayor
he or she also has a percentage higher
again because of the additional work
that's required in supporting the mayor
at additional maintenance
so
these rates they're all in the
handbook
chairpersons of community boards are
paid twice as much as a community board
member
and these rates are reviewed by the
authority
for july 1 of next year
[Music]
so that gives you an indication there
any burning questions and i will hand
over to anthony
for the fun but they all came to us
about the nomination process
all right
everyone good evening thanks for coming
along um
especially thanks tonight because it's
really rough night out there so hold on
everybody for getting here
um so i'm the electoral officer for
waimakariri dc again this time around
and i'm going to take you through
the nomination process so what's the
process to go through to get your name
in as a candidate for start off and then
some of the do's and don'ts you can
can't do if you get into that
campaigning mode which is
further down the track
um
can i
drive that sarah
i just want to take you through a little
bit about
our position so i'm unemployed by
elections.com
which is the name suggested as a
election management company
based in christchurch
we are doing elections all the time and
everybody your usual question is what
you do when you're not doing council
elections
and we're typically doing
a range of about 200 elections a year
some of them will be quite small as in
just
chamber of commerce elections those sort
of things where there's only two or
three dozen
members voting for a board that can
range and then across to
bigger organizations like
fonterra and
a lot of cooperatives we get involved
with those type of actions also a lot of
power trust elections and a lot of
uv settlements so all that sort of stuff
is going on behind the scenes as we're
behind the open body elections
um but that keeps us more than busy as a
rule and then every three years we get
to the
busy period when training accounts
elections
are required
and we get engaged in this case we're
engaged by those councils at the bottom
of the slides
um
regional councils on the top line and
then below that all the city councils
that have engaged us this time around
and for most of those we're engaged at
both the or for both public accounting
and electoral officer services
so this time around sarah she's pointed
out is my
lady on the ground here she's the front
of the house person if you like that's
going to be handling most of your
nomination documents and most of your
queries if you come into the building
and on the back and grow supporting
sierra with any support and backup she
needs on that
and cereal will have some other
crew here to help with formations during
busy times in the world
um what is the role well it's basically
the conductor
or that much of a batter sammy exactly
it's really a fully administrative role
we have to do as sarah says compile
all of things like
notices and
electoral roles
and during due course we get into the
voting documents compliance writing
documents and putting those out and of
course as candidates you guys get
interested in accounting so we'll go
through that in a little bit more detail
later on
we don't have much control over the
campaigning side of things well enough
because there's next to no legislation
about
or giving us any control over that
so about all we can get excited about is
whether there's a thing called an
authorization statement on your campaign
and i'll cover that off in a little bit
more detail
we're trying to give you a level playing
field firstly so that you've got a
mechanism to make yourself a candidate
if that's what you want to do
and then ultimately from there
good voting process underway senate
a good focus
rearray can vote for you if they choose
right next one zero
um here's your time frame for this time
around i'm not going to go through all
those dates
they're all in the handbook and there's
serious notes there's copies over there
available for you
but i will point out the first one
which is that first 8th of july date
won't mean a lot to most of you but if
you're intending to stand as a candidate
that's when you absolutely have to start
reporting candidate expenses from
and if you're lucky enough to get some
donations those as well potentially
we'll go into that in a little bit more
detail throughout the track
then um beyond that obviously nomination
period is open now you've got
effectively
four weeks to get your nominations in we
hope you don't take
four weeks
don't leave it to the last day please
so there'll be a message going through
several times on various slides saying i
don't need it the last one
um
but those nominations close on the 12th
of august this year
and that's an absolute cut-off we can't
give you any extra time because you left
it with enabler to drop in and they had
an accident or
somebody's had a fire or whatever the
case may be and get those
problems every three years somebody will
ring us in fact we'll have to have
conversations with about three or four
people around the country
where those sort of things have happened
they've left their nomination to the
last day
hoping somebody would run it in for them
hopefully there'd be no problems with it
but it turns out they were and we have
to it's a very uncomfortable discussion
to have when somebody's made the
intention of standing and we have to
tell them that sadly through that
process we can't accept the nomination
beyond that the voting starts in earnest
in september and closest 8th of october
you'll get some results on the 8th of
october
so those are the
positions that are up for
contention this time around
same as last time if you've been through
the process
before um other than a little bit of
shuffle in the some of the subdivisions
for the community
yeah
so sarah's probably one of those
slides earlier so other than that is
anybody here specifically interested in
ecan positions
no okay i'll just ask that because
i'm also the electoral officer for ecamm
as it happens
and
this is a slide because we've been
hosted one white macaroon dc here
tonight this is all focused on my
macaroni dc stuff but it's
i was going to swing across and look at
anything if anybody had an interest in
the um in the e-collections
so this is the nomination process itself
and again there's a lot of information
here we'll make the slide available
online so you can go ahead and look at
the details in your own time for the
track but
the top few bits are important here so
if you want to stand as a candidate you
do have to submit a nomination document
and it does have to be valid
i'll show you
slide one further into the presentation
there's copies over here to take away
tonight
but in addition to that nomination
document
you need to pay two hundred dollars for
each position you want to stand for
it is a deposit of sorts so
if you
are successful in your election process
you will get that 200 back
if you're not successful and you hold
within 25
of the lowest poland successful
candidate you also get that deposit back
so it's really if you
don't do very well at all that you
potentially lose that deposit so just
keep that in mind we also want some
evidence of the new zealand citizenship
because you need to be a citizen to
stand
it catches a few people out
so we'll just ask for a copy advice for
the person something like that
and the last two items here are optional
but most people choose to put them in
which is the little piano profile that
goes in with the
loading booklet that comes out with
loading papers
and a photo that comes again we'll go
through those in a little bit more
information detail
it doesn't have to be a current valid
passport i'm just looking that you're a
new zealand citizen
we'll ask you if you state if your
citizenship status
just bottom one i'm going to point out
to you because
as candidates your information is sought
by other people
usually for a startup it's somebody
trying to sell you something as in some
advertising space in a newspaper or
something to send me some signage or
something um but equally some you know
some of the electors will want to get
hold of you from time to time
if there's a meet the candidates meeting
usually they're hosted by some of the
service organizations around the place
the jc's or the
so they will want to know how to get
hold of you and your information or some
of your details will be available from
the website in due course
initially it will just be your name as a
confirmed candidate then there'll be a
file goes out with email addresses and
the like for people get a lot of it
so just be aware of that
all right what's on the next one sarah
so these ones i will go through because
they're reasonably
important the first one hopefully is for
the obvious i think we'll be seeing here
if you're serving the three incidents
but you can't stand for both ecan and a
council within the ecan area
so that's just something to keep in mind
there
if you've got an interest in a contract
of more than 25 000
or your
partner or business associate has
that also may be a sticking point for
you there's a process to go through to
see whether you can get
excluded from that particular
requirement
through the office of the authority
general but it's just something to keep
in mind and you can't nominate yourself
you need to have two other people that
are enrolled in the area that you want
to stand for to support your nomination
but you can stand for
several
council issues if you're some pride so
you could stand for one of the community
boards
so you as a candidate don't need to live
in the area that you're looking to stand
for but their nominators do
and as soon as they role
council employee but that's very limited
so it won't go into any great detail on
that
there's a note before you have to be a
new zealand citizen
and you have to be enrolled on a
parliamentary electoral role somewhere
in new zealand
so you don't have to live in that
district if that's
what the situation is for you but your
two nominators which is the next point
do have to they have to be enrolled
on the council's electoral roll or
having just recently enrolled you can
confirm that they are in the area that
you wanted to stand for
and we do ask that you provide all your
nomination documents together when you
run that
in that moment
because it just speeds up the process
seriously
the last bit there was
a little bit to keep in mind which is
once you've put a nomination in you've
got until the close of nominations to
withdraw
freely
beyond that it'll be on the 12th of
august in this case you can only
withdraw with a medical certificate that
says you've suffered something capacity
that now makes you
enabled or unable to
carry out that
position
so in that court if you've got a memory
from back in 2019 on the hunter officer
also from the kinsey district council
and julian lee from the seventh sharp
team did a bit of us
stunt where he decided to try and boost
the
number of nominations by putting in a
nomination himself or near
and his nomination was all
good and dandy and i spoke to him a
couple times and he was all
quite dedicated to the to the cause and
was going to
campaign hard
and on that i didn't actually think to
mention to him that he if he ever wanted
to withdraw he had to do it before a
certain date but anyway he rang me after
about
two years after the nomination very
close and said oh no that was that
wasn't actually serious i wanted a draw
now
and i had to go to him and say well you
can't unless you can go up the medical
center
and he had a small army of people in
auckland trying to get you off the hook
basically in the end he had to remain in
the race which cost the council some
money because he wasn't he wasn't sharp
enough with these withdrawal process
so just keep that in mind um
that's a
high level shot by the nomination form
if you've been through the nomination
process before you'll be familiar with
the layout
on the front side we're not going to go
through the whole thing but on the front
side you've got the candidate details
and the nominator details below that
so section b is for the candidate
details to go in and that's where we
release some of that information
into that spreadsheet that gets
made available and below that should
nominate details so your two nominators
have to sign to support your nomination
there's a couple of little fields in
there that i will point out so above the
signature bottom for the candidate to
sign
there's a field there that asks for
name to be shown on the voting document
and we ask you to give some thought to
that because if you leave that blank
then we'll put your full name
and your full name might be three or
four given names plus your surname
and when you see your name on the loan
document it'll be quite odd when you
know that everybody else has just asked
for their first name
so that particular field is important
when you come to that have a think about
how your what name you want to be shown
in the voting document let us know
um below that is an affiliation field
and you've got
an opportunity to claim an affiliation
if you want
uh historically that used to be for
people that were associated with you
know major political parties like the
labour party with the national party the
greens money that sort of thing
but now that's getting a little bit more
wider in the scheme of things that
people are claiming
not so much affiliations but more
campaigning terms that they might be
known by so they'll have little
campaigning
duties if you like the um free parking
in rangiora or something like that just
so that that gives them focus for their
campaign and we're reasonably relaxed
about that you can have you can claim
that as long as it's less than 38
characters long as long as it's not
offensive
we will allow that
but we will have the right to come back
here if it does look
suspicious or likely to cause some grief
or confusion
on the back of the nomination form is
just some bank account information
there's eligibility
criteria at the top there and at the
bottom
we'll be excited about that
there is a field
below the council bank account
section there where we ask you to put
your bank account details in so that
when you get your deposit back assuming
we'll get your deposit back
we know where to send it back to without
having to chase yourself
doing other things
that's just a blown up version of that
same bank account section so if you're
wanting to pay your your nomination
deposit by paint b
that's the bank account information
you'll need and below that is that
little section to put your
so the candidate profiles and statements
so the profiles firstly these are the
little
snippets of bios that go in the little
booklet going out with the voting papers
so they're not mandatory but most
candidates will put one in
if you're going to put one in then we
ask you to send it to us electronically
and these days it's usually by now an
email to sarah
either before you jump into the
nomination documents or when you're
sending your nominations through so you
can actually just email the whole thing
through
or if you're bringing it in and you
haven't ordered them by the time you see
sarah she'll probably ask you to email
to her rather find your way home or when
you get up
and the logic for that is that we don't
really want to retype or profile
because the opportunity for error then
sneaks in and
your opportunity to fix that is pretty
limited
so your profiles will go on the council
website
sometime
towards the end of the month that's
august or earlier or early september
but by then the printing of those will
be underway so we don't release them
typically until they have been signed
off
and the printers have then got that
process underway
that's then when you'll see them
probably the first time there's a
candidate and if we have re-typed them
for some reason and made a cache of that
then there's no really no opportunity
for you to fix it so our preference is
you've sent us that profile as a word
document there's an attachment to an
email or in the email itself we just
click copy and paste it
and
there's minimal input or opportunity for
error there
we'll bring in an rpm drive with your
photo
do you guys call out androids
okay
a lot of councils right now
similarly with the pro with the photos
if you can attach that to
the email or
run it on android um if you're bringing
in a photo if you're getting a photo
done which again most people will do
just make sure it's a good clear shot of
your head and shoulders because that's
what it'll get cropped down to
so just a photo of yourself not the
holiday group that you just had with the
two dozen relatives
and no
nothing that's going to obscure your
head so no sunglasses no scars no
hats that sort of thing
if you're going to take it yourself and
most
cameras these days on most phones these
days will take a good high resolution if
i don't
just take it against the light colored
walls or something around that spot
but don't take it against a window
or on any other side so this is just too
much
opportunity
we can come back to that so this is an
example of how it comes out in the
book in this case we've covered together
a profile for one of my colleagues who
does some other election stuff he's an
actual officer for most of the northern
councils that we
engage us
and you can see there that it states the
council the standing forward states the
position that this particular candidate
is standing for it states his name
below that it's got his affiliation so
we've cracked all that information off
the
nomination form
and then below that there's two other
blocks there which says
where his principal place of residence
is and we pick that up from one of the
tick boxes on the
nomination pool
and also in this case he's standing for
another issue and he's filled that in
from the nomination
and then
his 150 words would start below that
so that all that information is plucked
off the nomination form
and your 150 words starts beyond that so
the tip i can give you and i can't give
you many tips is if you're going to do
an account profile don't waste your 150
words by starting it with my name is and
i'm standing for
because it's going to be fairly obvious
that's the case okay you only get 150
words which is pretty miserable so let's
just spend it on what you actually want
to convey
all right so look at the campaign side
of things
some of you will campaign something you
won't it's up to you
um
there's no kickoff time you could have
actually started
last year if you wanted some of those
christchurch councillors
candidates have been campaigning
earlier this year
but as i noted earlier
if you are going to campaign
then the costs for that need to be
recorded
and certainly all costs happening from
the 8th of july
need to be accounted for in this
declaration that you then submit after
the
voting period is finished
and occasionally you have to prograd or
anything that happens before that so
these guys that are campaigning in
christchurch if they have incurred costs
that continues into that campaign period
and some of that early campaign costs
would have to come into their
candidate declaration expense
declaration
but if you get a campaign you need to
keep away from council's resources and
we're going to cover that off in a
little bit more detail within the track
as well but the main things to keep away
from are council's logo
principle
and then obviously use of buildings and
other resources social media channels
we'll cover that off again
items that
aren't typically made available for
general public use
as candidates we don't encourage you to
collect voting papers so it's a postal
vote again there's usually a mechanism
there for them to return their vote
but if they are stuck
try and keep away from you collecting
them or being seen to be collecting
voting documents because it's just
from your
perspective see if they've got another
family member that can help them get it
to a
post bin or whatever the case may be but
if they can't then obviously you can't
try and help out there but as a first of
course try and see if something else can
help them out
[Music]
you
those expenses just to
confirm
if you get a campaign
any expenses are your expenses so
there's no magical money comes out of
the council after the process to say
here have some money back for your
campaign
it's your cost
or in some cases if you've managed to
get some donations you can offset some
of that cost that way
but any of that campaign material must
have an authorization statement that's
the thing that i have to get distracted
by
as the electoral officer
historically
it had to be
your name and a physical address or your
agent's name and their physical address
but as from the beginning of this month
those rules have been relaxed and you've
now got more options to avoid the
listing or physical address
you can now list your books or a website
or a mobile phone number or something
like that so long as that information is
well then
the
person's inquiry
can then contact you from wherever that
um
just keep in mind that whatever you put
out there in camp and campaigning
material needs to be factual because
it's
subject to the advertising standards
associate authority
and they can investigate
complaints
and
the usual rules of defamation applies so
anybody can sue you if to start
claiming false things as part of the
campaign material hopefully that doesn't
happen much in the
rural areas it's more of a big city
saga generally
but that's
the campaign side of things particularly
the expense sort of thing so just
quickly on the donation side of things
sarah what's
oh so it's an expenditure limit sorry
so if you are going to campaign
then those are the limits that you can
spend up to most people don't go
anywhere near them but keep in mind that
that is the limits you can go up to
um and if you get a campaign for more
than one position then it's the highest
level position only that you can go
to cobble them together and say on seven
so up
or three positions i can have three
chunks
all right again that's in the handbook
and uh
most of that information is
already there i think we've covered most
of that off um just keep in mind that
declaration that you need to sign so we
will send you
a declaration form
once the nomination period is finished
confirm candidates will get a
declaration form and that's that form
that you need to submit to outline any
expenses that you've spent on
campaigning
or any donations that are over a certain
level
and that's in a
document for public inspection and the
council will put it on the website for
like seven years
that's
available for anybody to come and check
if they're saying what and some people
will
but anyway just keep in mind that even
if you don't spend anything you still
need to submit a declaration so it's
going to be a little decoration but you
need to decide to say you haven't spent
and you deposit nominations so it
doesn't count as an expense
that's right
oddly enough that's not an
and oddly enough the other thing is that
it wasn't back until that declarations
you've seen so if you're waiting
wondering why you haven't got 200
um just quickly on the donation side of
things it's not a big factor in the
rural elections as a rule but some of
the bigger metro
councils will have political parties
that will fund some donations to certain
candidates
if you are in the position where you
have received the donation of over 1500
you have to declare that so you have to
put that in your declaration form
and you can't split that or arrange for
that donation level to be split to avoid
that 1500 level so if you are aware of a
donation coming from particular group or
organization a particular person
that has been split you then need to
combine that in your declaration and
show it as
a donation made up of contributions
again it's fairly rare
for the donation side of things maybe on
the mayoral side
from there they make it donations
we actually
suggest that as candidates although
you're only required to look to list
donations over 1500
you may actually want to consider
listing any donations you receive
just so that it's on public record
that's who's my contribution to your
campaign
you would probably need to discuss that
with the donor because they may not be
comfortable with that but it's just a
point we've
pointed out you may want to think about
that because your donations are
those declarations are available for
public inspection for further seven
years at least
and people may want to go back
if they see you discussing something
with
or about a particular group organization
and they're aware that you've received
the donations that are online
if it's not declared then they may want
to make it
all right um signage again see some more
detail on the handbook some of you may
choose to put up signage some of you
won't
um but in this case for waimakariri it's
6th of august that you've signed up from
and you need to take them down by the
7th of october if you can't put them up
personally i just get excited about
whether it's got the authorization
statement or not sarah on the other hand
will be more
required to keep in mind the council by
law side of things about the size of the
signage and
making sure it hasn't got flashing
lights and other things that will
distract motorists like um
so those are the general items to be
aware of
so in this case any complaints will come
back to serum first instance
which we'll
get on the phone and see whether what
needs to be sorted out
nzta
they've put their own set of guidelines
for signage adjoining state highways
do you remember line side road as a
state highway as well
all right so those that's the signage
side of things um again more information
on the handbook about that
here's a couple of signs
a couple of examples of good and bad
signs
so the one on the left has got a
stylized tick or the candidate
one tick candidate is fine as soon as
you get into this
vote for me and not for others you are
effectively imitating a voting document
and that's an offence
so the one on the right is although it's
got the authorization statement which is
one of the things i get excited about
can't do that because they're suggesting
that they vote for somebody else
and or don't vote for somebody else in
this case
the other thing to be a reminder is that
that particular problem also services
when the voting documents go out
and candidates are quite private and
work quite prone in the early days of
facebook
open their voting government mark they
vote on paper and put a photo of it on
facebook saying look at me i'll buy it i
hope we're gonna do the same
very important but again it comes into
this category here you're now promoting
you can vote for or could be seen the
promotion that you vote for
with a voting document which is an owner
we spend about the next two or three
days telling people to take those photos
so just keep that in mind um
so that's a good and bad example the
next one's probably a little bit too
honest
so this is a guy up with one of
warwick's
councils up little bottom
and he was actually going to stand for
council but we had to get older and tell
him that he signed and have the
authorisation statement on it which when
he got the stitch with the bureaucracy
and pulled out
but everybody was quite amused of this
side of the process
social media um
yeah so there's well each council will
have a social media policy
um
more information about that in the
handbook but effectively it's their
resource
and they will be
keen to be seen to be politically
neutral particularly during the
election period so
they will
bump
anybody with posts to those social media
pages and channels that have any hint of
campaigning activity
so
just keep that in mind stick to your own
channels stick your own messaging and
you won't come up stuck there
again if you're going to do social media
campaigning it's just another
campaigning process needs that
authorization statement
and
i think facebook is a bit messy on that
side of things where
you actually need to specify that you
want the words
[Music]
your posts that come
later on so you don't have to put it in
the bottom of every pot every post
on top of that top healer and it's clear
when we open up that facebook page
on the actual campaigning though that
will need to be on the actual campaign
material
so
each push goes out with the
authorization statement effectively
page up there as long as that
authorization statement is on there
somewhere you can see it it covers the
page itself if you're doing any
advertising
then that's just another moment of
advertising and it needs that
organization
offences
i won't get too excited about these
because i'm sure you're all
getting up
but there's more information in the
handbook if you really want to get down
to that level
um
the ones that isn't earlier the ones
that tend to trip people up imitation
voting paper
and
also the treating thing comes into play
occasionally
so
as candidates you have to be
fairly limited in what you can do
in the way of promotional materials so
you can't be seen to be giving away
items of value
and this is where it gets frustrating
because an item of value can get down to
the pen or something like that
these are some of the things that people
have brushed off in the past and done
i'm going to put some material out there
i'm going to give away a pen or i'm
going to give away a
magnet or whatever the case may be but
as soon as it's got some item you've
gone into it you're potentially in the
gun from other candidates to
put on a complaint and we need to then
stop doing
so don't don't get
too excited about giving away materials
with your campaign
[Music]
that's effectively what's called
treating
if you're holding a campaign meeting of
some sort you can provide refreshments
um
so anything else on that side of things
typically gets passed to the police once
we've done our cursory look
so the process itself so assuming you've
got
down to this level when you're
engaged in campaign sort of things some
of you may want to buy an electoral roll
it's an opportunity for you
it's available to you if you want
we can only supply that to you in hard
copy
so
the value of that these days is fairly
limited but if you want to
you need to come back to sierra and ask
her for that
she'll put one off
if you want an electronic
copy you need to apply to the
registration sorry the electoral
commission
to do
there's a process for that in the
handbook
but they need to see that you are a
confirmed candidate before they will
release that information to you and
it'll cost you about 450 dollars
but historically some of the candidates
particularly the bigger metro areas
would use that for mail-outs and the
like
these days of price of postage that's
getting less and less attractive so i'm
just not sure
whether that's still of interest to you
but the printed copies of the electoral
role you can
source if you want to
and use them as some sort of talk
about a certain people on the street or
whatever the case may be
the voting process itself
it is still a postal voting process as
we said
so again one of the few things i can
tell you if you're doing some
campaigning is think about when you're
going to get your campaign material out
there
because the voting packs will get
delivered or the deliveries will start
on the 16th of september
so if you're thinking about doing some
campaigning
it's a good idea usually to have that
out about on around that time because a
lot of people will get their voting
paper and vote on it straight away
others will set up
there'll be about a third of them will
vote and know who they want to vote for
from the book of information and
whatever they've seen locally leading up
to that point
so
most people will
be able to mail that information back in
they'll be replying
postal pack
occasionally some people will not
receive that information you know
because they weren't enrolled or the
dog active voting paper or whatever the
case may be you as candidates may get
asked how can i get a replacement paper
so direct them to sarah she's through
she'll organize the special voting
documents
and which is effectively the same
process as the main voting process
except that the candidate or the
applicant has to sign a declaration to
save your budget
so there's an extra piece of paperwork
for them
but
as candidates we really don't recommend
that you get involved in that process
so don't go saying i'll go in and see
sarah and bring you back some special
learning papers because sarah won't see
the face out of that
but
you can
recommend that this is how they go about
getting that
replacement
so the results this is down to the sharp
end now
we'll have results out
within a couple of hours generally on
the saturday of the 8th of october
and sarah will then
be in touch with you as candidates can
you get it yeah
we bring in
we'll try
we won't tell you anybody else's results
when we've contacted everybody that
afternoon
then we post up on the building here and
on the website
um everybody's results
so given there's a fair number of
positions available and there'll be a
reasonable number of candidates involved
that running around might take
but just keep an eye on the website keep
refreshing the page if that's what we've
been doing
it will come through
so that's the progress result that's
effectively 95 of it
just keep in mind that if you
are in a close race
those positions can change so that's
only a progress result the next people
have resolved out is this thing like
call the preliminary result
that typically won't come out until
at best very late on saturday night but
more likely sunday
once we've got hold of all the documents
or the waiting papers that have been
physically dropped off so these are the
ones that weren't in the mail channel
have arrived some other ways usually
through the council office
we round those up and once we can
confirm that we've processed all those
that preliminary result will go out
so that'll be a small increment within
extra clothing tattoos
and again those results may have changed
from the progress result so that's a
better result but it's still not the
final result
final result will come out
usually by the wednesday but
typically at the latest by the thursday
when we've processed the special rates
and for the special votes we need to go
through some of them back to the
electoral commission to verify
the applicant's enrolments and that
dates several days in some cases so
that's when there's a lag with that
process
um so that final result will come out
and get posted on the council website as
soon as it's available once that's out
then it's nailed down as far as the
result goes unless somebody
watches an appeal or a recap process
now what do you call a close vote when
those first numbers come out 50 votes
four or five
voting the votes will get tallied twice
individually
through our normal process and then when
we get down to close results so when
this
12th or 12 moon thing takes over
we will still be we'll go away and we'll
look double check any real close ones so
if we see something that's got a margin
of
10 or low 10 or lower something like
that
we'll run through again
those particular particular special
votes and anything it was
anything that was processed that
required separate validation so we'll go
through and look at those that may not
come out before the
preliminary result comes out even but it
will come out before that final result
comes out
by the time that final result comes out
we'll have at least triple checked
those results
now keeping that in mind
it is possible and it happened
last in 2019
where somebody did have a recount where
there was a margin of one
and there was one vote found that
was interpreted as a scribble out in
actual fact though
the
judicial officer said no i'm not
accepting that as a scribble out and it
was uh what happened was it then it
swung the other way
so
the second came around because it was a
vote for the
person that was winning
and he picked up the other one and as it
happened
the person that was second didn't really
want to get elected anyway but that's
what happened as a result of enrique
that's politics he was best friends with
the guy that was elected and between
them they
somehow through the recount process and
that's how it washed out
but generally any post results will have
gone through at least three times before
it's finalized
and we're reasonably certain that that's
what the result will be but it doesn't
stop you having that right to lodge a
recount application if you're going to
do that cost 750 you have to do it
through the court you probably want to
involve a solicitor or something that's
not a straightforward process in the odd
thing that came out of that what i just
discussed was
just prior to that another candidate in
another election
watched the application for recount
where the margin was about 10
and the judge
threw it out because he said you haven't
given me any evidence to suggest that
the process was sufficient for
everything and i'm not satisfied that a
marginal team
is
close enough to call for recap
so
it was a bit of a surprise to us that he
needed something other than the
closeness of the result
to support the application for recap
which shows you sometimes that's when
solicitor can be abused
it's a fairly rare event
we haven't had that case
in fact in canterbury i think there's
been one recount for our community in
the
last 10 years
and it was really just because
in fact i think we can just get that
time
anyway um so this is the coming into
office apart this is a bit sarah and her
crew will
more involved in but is
if you are successful in the election
process you don't come into office until
the day after that final result
gets posted on the council website
nowadays so historically it used to be
you had to wait for the final result to
be published in the paper and then you
didn't come into office until the day
after that
now the legislation has been changed
it's now as soon as it hits the website
it's the day after that will come into
office
you can't actually do anything until the
events
which is the first
normal meeting which sarah and the team
will be in touch with you to discuss
dates and processes and
what's required
yeah to give you a little bit of lead in
time because
many candidates are working and
things
we will in the
few weeks leading up to the election we
will actually send you a couple of notes
giving you
key dates that we would like you to come
in for training
and preparation ahead of actually being
sworn in so we give you some induction
training so that you
feel a little bit more comfortable for
the first four meeting and know what
processes to expect after that
so election day is saturday we
traditionally will get all confirmed
elected members
in here on the tuesday
for an afternoon
meet and greet learn a few things about
the processes and then over the next
fortnight
leading up into that swearing-in session
we will actually have different training
sessions
we'll have different ones for community
board members and counsellors and we'll
also have some collective ones
so that you are prepared going forward
and we will assist you um we might just
throw you around the table and leave you
to it
we will help you through the processes
and then so we will give you a little
bit of forewarning
leading into that last month of the
election
so that if you are working on things you
can actually say to the boss hey i'm
going to need this tuesday off and maybe
thursday morning for a few hours off or
whatever to help your planning um
and then for the next three months
there'll be ongoing support and training
then we'll give you a little bit of a
break and then we'll do another few
months of helping you on different
stages
through the whole council processes
yes so quickly
in terms of resources i think that
canada handbook is your best resource
initially
also some of the good information on
that council's website
and then those other documents here
available if you really want to
go further than that
i think
we look to the last slide so
for me the bottom line says it all
i do hope that
if you decide to stand as a candidate
that you are sure the best
um hopefully i'm not chasing you on the
authorization statement
but before that but um do get your
nomination in the next place if you're
thinking about doing it because there's
no
prizes for being the last candidate in
the nation
there's a lot of risk associated with
that
and we will start updating the website
from the end of this week with confirmed
candidates
so your name will be out there sooner
that you get your paperwork in and we
confirm that behind the scenes
sooner it's on the list so you get a
little bit more exposure the sooner they
give you papers
so that comes off what i wanted to
present to you and um
just
open up to anybody that's got any
questions there is to
fill in
[Music]
but the real price
what do you have to put on here
um you have to put on there your sorry
the um
the
[Music]
no well yeah but sometimes as you say
it's discounted so sometimes when it is
discounted you need to
declare reasonable value for that
service or
whatever it is that you are listing as
the expense
so
sometimes it's not quite as
straightforward as you think usually
there's an invoice to support it
which is another thing you don't need to
submit that paperwork with your
decorations so you just need your
decoration but you need to hang on to
your paperwork to support
any appeal that somebody will challenge
that anybody raises against your
declaration
but yeah it's it's tricky sometimes when
there is a discount involved it's
effectively the
the true public or sorry the true cost
of whatever it is that reasonable market
value or whatever it is that you just
paid for
anything else
[Music]
i do encourage you to um ensure that the
family are aware of how much time that
you will be involved and that they are
fully supportive
for
funny phone calls at odd times of the
day and night you being
out three nights a week at various
meetings you tied up on
you know saturday afternoons and some
community events and things um
family support
is really really important to get you
through the three years as well as the
support that you'll be provided with
account
with other elected members and with the
staff
any queries just send me an email to
that elections at wmk email address and
we'll
try and work through any of your queries
that you have
so i look forward to receiving some
nominations
[Music]
you